breaking news the business secretary
Grant chaps has confirmed the
government's decision to back the size
well see nuclear power plant in Suffolk
well in September Boris Johnson promised
700 million pounds worth of funding for
the project the business secretary says
nuclear is an important feature of
Britain's long-term energy security
one thing I think we can be very proud
of as we produce more offshore wind than
any other country in the world over half
of our power uh you know for the for a
day was produced by offshore wind a
couple of weeks ago very significant
indeed but we know the wind doesn't blow
all the time so you've got to have that
combination we're standing right by one
of our nuclear power part plants this is
going to add to that as we see others
potentially decommissioned in the years
to come I think that mix as Energy
Secretary I think that mix of having
nuclear having wind of having solar of
having various different forms of power
is critically important
well our business and economics
correspondent gurpreet no one is uh here
for more on this girlfriend I guess the
key Point here is how all this is going
to be funded
yeah the government confirming the first
state-backed nuclear projects in the UK
for more than 30 years with a 700
million pound investment there have been
some doubts in recent months about
whether this project would actually go
ahead in light of the state of um the
public finances and the government
stated aimed to rein in uh public
spending but the chancellor in his
budget earlier this month confirmed the
need for cheap low carbon reliable
energy it's something he reiterated
again today saying that this project
would be the biggest step towards uh
Britain's energy Independence but for
the talk of sovereignty as you've uh
rightly just pointed out there are still
question marks over how this is going to
be funded that 700 million uh pound
investment announced by the government
today it's a drop in the ocean when you
consider the cost of building something
like this which could run into 20 to 30
billion pounds possibly higher if you
look at the sister project Hinckley
Point C which is running billions of
pounds over over budget and is taking
about a decade longer and then it was
initially expected to do so along with
EDF the French energy giant the
government will hold a 50 stake in this
project but that still leaves quite a
big shortfall that needs to be found and
that money could come from foreign
investors initially China's State
nuclear energy was involved in the
project but it's been slowly edged out
the government has wasn't comfortable
with the process aspect of Chinese
involvement there have been talks in
recent days that The emirati Sovereign
wealth fund is eyeing up an investment
too so it's far from a done deal just
yet and crucially for consumers it will
be a while before they benefit from any
of this it could be well into the middle
of the next decade before we start
seeing any energy from this plant and in
the interim energy bills will be going
up because of a nuclear Levy that will
be imposed onto household bills
somewhere in the region of one to four
pounds so this is very much a long-term
solution to an immediate crisis all
right go free thanks for that